>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Wendy Rieger: I, my father
who lived to be 93 and drove
until he was 91 used to say to
me, "Growing old is not for wimps"
and I just turned 60 this
year and I, so thank you.
[ Applause ]
You get applause for 60 now.
I must be old.
Kidding. But it's and being an aging
anchor on television is just loads
of fun, you know, keeping everything
together with spanks and duct tape.
But I'm a baby boomer.
I'm sort of on the end
of the baby boomers
and I think baby boomers have,
we have been creating the
revolutions you know since 1968,
1969 and I think also we in terms
of aging so many of us have watched,
I know I did, watch my
parents grow old and die
and thought, oh my
God that was ugly.
I don't want to go, do it that
way and so I think we are ready
for a revolution and we are ready
to start leaving bread crumbs
for the generations behind us
those millennials, you know,
those dastardly millennials.
You know and I think well you
know while we're not ready
to sack the temple of youth, I
think we need to build a temple
for being older and mature
and having mastery and smarts
and getting a clue, which
I think is what you get
when you the loser collagen.
So, with that in mind, is an honor
to welcome Jo Ann Jenkins who's
the CEO of AARP and author of,
I love the title, the national
bestseller "Disrupt Aging"
and we are here today
because of her.
Did you know that she started
his national Book Festival?
Yes she did yes.
[ Applause ]
If 60 gets applause then starting
the Book Festival should definitely
get applause.
She launched it in 2001 and
as the, she was the Library
of Congress' then chief
operating officer.
She led and expanded this
festival through 2010.
When they first started it they
had 5000 people, now as you know
if you've been out there are
150,000 people attending this,
yeah [applause].
And since joining AARP in 2010
and leading it since 2014,
Jo Ann has sponsored groundbreaking
work to transform AARP into a leader
in social change dedicated
to enhancing quality
of life for everyone as we age.
Her legacy of the Library
of Congress not only
includes establishing
and expanding this festival,
but also creating the Library
of Congress experience which is an
interactive pathway offering access
to the library's incomparable
collection.
That's a place where you need to go
spend months and she builts strong
and mutually supportive
relationships
with private sector sponsors so that
we have all of this great access.
And under her leadership AARP,
the vision there was we imagine
because you have to have
vision you have to keep sort
of recreating yourself as we
know as every decade goes by.
And you have to redefine
the challenges,
get rid of the outdated beliefs,
and really ignite some new insights
that allow people to adapt to
today's realities of aging;
she also just finished
a partnership with us.
We were so proud to be a part
of it and we were just talking
about to expand it next
year; the drive to end hunger
which was a multiyear nationwide
campaign which has donated
over 36 million meals
and provides support
to over 100 anti-hunger
organizations across the country.
So it is my privilege to welcome
to the 2016 National Book Festival
the best-selling author of the book
"Disrupt Aging; A Bold New
Path To Living You're Best Life
At Every Age", Dr. Jo Ann Jenkins.
[ Applause ]
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: Well
good afternoon everyone.
It has been my honor to serve for
15 years at the Library of Congress
and now to be the CEO at AARP,
my two favorite organizations
in the world.
I'd like to start and share some
thoughts you and then we'll open it
up for questions at end, but
let me start with this question;
how old would you be if you
didn't know how old you were?
Think about it for a moment.
>> Five.
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: Five.
It's an intriguing question.
How does your age affect the
way you behave, what you do
or what you don't do, and how
often do you get into societies
or the media's idea of what is old?
And then think about this, what if
you could lose your preoccupation
with age and just put
it outside of your mind?
What if of instead
of being preoccupied
with aging, we focus more on living?
Would you behave any differently?
Would you treat other
people differently
or would you be happier
and enjoy life more?
I love to tell the story about the
Hall of Fame pitcher Satchel Paige.
Satchel Paige joined the Cleveland
Indians in 1948 and help lead
to the American League
Pennant that year.
That was the first year he had in
the majors, though he had played
in the Negro leagues
for almost 20 years.
He was somewhere in his mid40s.
I'm being made vague,
because Satchel Paige
never knew how old he was.
Today it's hard to find players
who play over the age of 40
and playing past 50 was unheard
of, but Satchel Paige did just that
and reporters would constantly ask
him, "How can you play at your age?
What keeps you going?"
How? He would simply say, because
he didn't know how old he was,
his age didn't keep him from
performing the way he knew he could.
"Age is a question of mind
over matter", he would say.
"If you don't mind,
it doesn't matter."
Well, for better or worse,
the overwhelming majority
of Americans do know how old they
are, and unlike Satchel Paige,
they do allow their pre-perceptions
of age to influence how they behave.
And I wrote this wrote
this book, "Disrupt Aging"
to change the conversation
in this country
about what it means
get older and it's not
about aging it's about living.
And it really is, I hope
giving people the opportunity
to embrace aging as something
to look forward to rather
than something to fear, to see this
period of your life not as a period
of declined but a period of growth;
to recognize the opportunities
not just the challenges
and perhaps most importantly, to
see themselves as contributors
to society and not burdens.
Here is the premise in a nutshell.
We need to change the
conversation in this country
about what it means to grow older.
The way people are aging is
changing, but many attitudes
and stereotypes about
aging have not.
We need to challenge these
old stereotypes and attitudes
and spark new solutions so more
people can choose how they want
to live and how they to age.
Disrupt aging is not only about
changing the conversation,
it's also about changing the reality
of aging, our individual behaviors,
our social norms, public policies
and private sector practices
and it encompasses changing
the culture; how we perceive,
what we believe, and how we behave
as individuals as institutions
and collectively as a society.
So make no mistake about it,
the way we are aging is changing
and mostly for the better.
Consider this, 10,000
people a day are turning 65
and that trend is going to continue
for at least the next 14 years.
Over the next two decades,
the number of people age 65
and older will nearly double to
72 million or 1 in 5 Americans
and by 2050, people 60 and older
will outnumber children 15 and under
for the first time in our history.
The fastest growing age group,
people of the age of 85,
and the second over
the age of a 100.
And if that doesn't make you
stop and think, picture this;
picture a 10-year-old maybe
it's your son or daughter
or granddaughter, grandson,
niece or nephew,
that 10-year-old a 50%
chance of living to be a 104.
And older he or she gets,
the odds even grow larger.
And some experts have already
predicted that the first person
who is ever going live to be
150 is already alive today.
Now let me pause here for
just a moment to point
out that this is truly a
remarkable achievement.
We've added more years to
the average life expectancy
since the 1900s than in all human
history up until this combined.
Today, because of increased
longevity
and generally better
health, we have opportunities
for continued productivity
and growth that our parents
and grandparents and
generations before us never had.
The good news is that the way
people are aging is changing
and it's mostly for the better.
The bad news is that many of
our beliefs and perceptions
of aging have not changed
and nor has the solutions
for supporting people as they age.
Our ability to live
longer, healthier,
more productive lives is one of
mankind's greatest accomplishments,
yet we don't see it that way we
often see it as a problem rather
than a solution and negative
stereotypes of aging are
so ingrained in our psyches that
they're difficult to overcome
and most of us don't even try.
We either just accept this
old stereotype and live
out this negative image
of aging or we deny,
like Wendy, that we're aging.
And we fight it with
every fiber of our being
and in some cases every
dollar in our bank account.
If you go to the Google search
engines and type in the bar "I lie
about my" The first word
that pops up is "aging."
We are a society obsessed with age.
Everyone wants to live long,
but nobody wants to get old.
I've always thought that the
comedian Larry Miller described
it best.
Some of you may have heard this.
He says, "Do you realize that the
only time in our lives when we'd
like to old is when we're kid?"
If you're less than
10-year-old you're so excited
about aging you think
about it in fractions.
How old are you?
I'm 4-and-a-half.
You're never 36-and-a-half and going
5, see this is where the key is.
You're going on.
You're so excited about
getting older you're going on.
You get into you're
teens and now you're
so thrilled you've
jumped to whole numbers.
How old are you?
I'm 16. I'm really 12, but I'm going
to be 16 and then the highlight
of that experience you become 21.
See even the word becomes,
sounds much more wonderful.
It's theatrical, magical,
you become 21.
But that's as good as it gets.
It all changes after that.
You're 4-and-a-half yes,
you're going to be 16 sure,
you become 21 yes that's OK, and
then all of a sudden you turn 30.
What happened here?
Turn, it sounds like
bad milk, you turn 30.
We had to throw him out.
So it's not much more
fun anymore is it?
Now it's getting ugly.
You become 21, you turn 30,
and now you're pushing 40.
Stay over there.
Forty, I'm pushing back,
but it doesn't stop there.
You become 21, you turn
30, you're pushing 40,
and finally you reach 50.
Oh, my dreams are gone.
But now it's going fast.
You become 21, you turn 30,
you're pushing 40, you reach 50
and all of a sudden you hit 60.
You become 21, you turn 30,
you're pushing 40, you reach 50,
you hit 60, and you make it to 70.
I didn't think I was
ever going to make it
and after that, is
a day by day thing.
You become tired.
You turn 43 and into your 90s
you start going backwards.
I was just 92.
But a strange thing happens folks.
If you can ever make it over
100 you become a kid again.
I'm a 104-and-a-half, okay.
We laugh of what Larry
Miller was talking
about because it's so
familiar to all us.
It's ingrained in our culture.
We've all seen those television ads
on TV and in magazines and says,
"50 is the new 30 or 60 is the
new 40", well while that may sound
like a nice sentiment
as someone over 50,
I don't agree with them at all.
Fifty is the new 50 and
it looks good, right.
>> Right.
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: Right, good.
[ Applause ]
I often tell people that
I have benefited immensely
from the experiences and the wisdom
that these years have brought me
and I wouldn't trade
them for anything,
besides we're not becoming younger
as we get older we can't
no matter how hard we try.
We're redefining what
needs to be our age.
It's not our own aging we need to
fight against, it's agest attitudes
and perceptions that permeates our
society which place such a huge part
and huge role in shaping
our culture.
And when we start to
change the perception
of aging, we change the culture.
So with that in mind, here's video
that created that illustrates some
of what I'm talking about.
I want you to keep in mind
that these actors thought
they were auditioning
for an intergenerational
documentary see what happens.
>> Hey, how's it going?
>> You can stand right
there that's your mark.
>> How you doing?
>> I'm great how are you?
>> Great.
>> Awesome.
Just tell us your first
name and your age.
>> My real age?
>> My name is Paolo.
I'm 25-years-old.
>> My name is Daniella and I'm 19.
>> Twenty-four.
>> Thirty-five.
>> Thirty-one.
>> Thirty-three.
>> I'm 26-years-old.
>> What age do you
consider to be old?
>> Late 40s.
>> Maybe 50.
>> Um.
>> I feel like 30 is the new
20, so I'd say like 40 is old.
>> I'd probably say 50s.
>> I'd like you to show me how an
old person would cross the street.
[ Music ]
>> I'm imagining that they
have some kind of cane.
[ Music ]
>> How would an old
person do a pushup?
[ Music ]
[ Coughing Sounds ]
>> And then they probably
couldn't get back up.
>> Show me how an old person
would send a text message.
[ Music ]
Do a jumping jack.
>> I'm like envisioning grandpa.
Grandpa you're not old, but.
[ Music ]
>> Okay. Hang on.
There's someone I want you to meet.
[ Music ]
>> Hello. I'm Burch.
I'm 66.
>> I'm Bob.
I'm 65.
>> Hi. I'm Daphne and I'm 68.
>> I'm Neil, 59.
>> I'm Dee and I'm 55.
>> George Basbinder
[assumed spelling], 75.
>> Wow.
>> My name is [inaudible].
I'm 70.
>> Nice to meet you.
>> We're going to give
you about 2 minutes
to teach each other something
that you are good at.
>> I can teach you a jump that I do.
>> Okay, please.
>> Both or your legs go
up and your arms goes up
and you pose for like 2 seconds.
>> Okay.
>> One, 2, 3; 1, 2, 3 lift; 1,
2, 3 and bring it to your heart
and bring it to your heart
add the head in, yeah.
I want to try to get your balance.
[Inaudible], okay now bring
your legs and your feet up.
>> Okay.
>> It's hard right?
>> Yeah. One, 2, 3 [grunting sound].
>> So we're going to switch.
You're just pretty much jumping,
so it's kind of like this.
You can go here, you
can balance with it.
>> Over, now fully.
Over, yeah.
>> One, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, so
when you come out the turn
like either way you go back
to that [inaudible], okay.
>> Squat like this and kneel.
Jab across and then
we'll go with this, okay.
[Inaudible].
>> Dalaney okay.
>> Got to whip it.
>> Whip it, okay.
>> Feel the sound?
>> Hear it.
>> Drive that bus.
>> Alright.
>> Now just waving to the people.
>> Oh, okay I like that
wave to the people okay.
>> Now age might you
consider to be old?
>> Probably 80 or 90.
He could just do everything
that I told him to do.
>> An age that I would consider
to be old now might be 100.
>> Do you remember what you said?
>> Yeah, yeah I said like in the
50s I thought that would old.
But what I thought [brief laughing].
>> It really changed my
thinking of what old is.
>> You've taught me something today.
Clearly there's no way
she's old, you know.
>> Now I know from today,
hey I don't look at age.
>> At my age I feel
capable of doing anything,
because I don't think I'm
limited in anything I can do.
>> At my age I feel like I
did when I was in my 20s.
>> At my age I feel like
I'm just getting started.
>> That's just when you put
together everything you've learned.
>> There's so many things
that I still want to do.
There's so many things
that I can do.
As long as I'm growing and
learning, then age doesn't matter.
>> When people start stopping,
that's when they start getting old.
>> Thank you.
Thank you so much.
>> Thanks Daphne.
>> It's great meeting you.
>> How long have you
been doing this?
Is this is new skill?
>> Forty years.
>> Wow.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: See what I mean?
You change the perceptions and
you begin to change beliefs.
Think about this way.
Today, it is socially
unacceptable to ignore, ridicule
or stereotype someone
based on their race,
or gender, or sexual orientation.
So why is still acceptable for
people to do this based on age?
Aging in not a problem
anymore than living is.
It's a human experience
and a natural part of life.
Muhammad Ali once said that "People
who see life the same way at 50
that they did at 20 has
wasted 30 years of life."
In today's world we might
add that people who see life
at 80 the same way they did at
50 have also wasted 30 years.
And so I won't pretend
that we aren't affected
by our aging process, we are.
But it's time we put aging
in its proper perspective.
We can't allow society whether
the media or advertisers
or a popular culture to
delude us into thinking we can
or should stay young forever.
That leads to this self-sense
of denial about who we are
and where we are in life,
and ultimately a feeling
of hopelessness and despair.
And my years at AARP have
confirmed for me that growing,
a growing number of people
who are 50 and older are ready
to change this conversation
about what means to get older.
We like where we are.
We're looking forward to the
years ahead and we're connecting
with more people in more meaningful
ways through our technologies.
We're committed to both our
family and energized by our work,
and we don't have to
make a choice we can
and have, but can and have both.
We are caregivers whether as
adult children taking care
of older parents, parents caring for
children or grandparents taking care
of grandkids or some
combination of all of these.
We're volunteers and
philanthropists and we are leaders
in our communities, supportive of
our churches, and helping hands
to our friends and neighbors.
We are a generation of makers
and doers who have a desire
to continue exploring
our possibilities
and to celebrate discovery
over decline and we seek
out these opportunities and grab
hold of them wherever we find them.
That optimism, that desire
to live life on its own terms
to make a difference is very
real and it confirms my belief
that no one's possibility
should be limited by their age
and that experience has value.
I also know that people face
real challenges every day.
Many struggled to meet their most
basic needs of health, financial,
caring for themselves or their
families and they don't want
to be limited or defeated
by these challenges.
They want win back their
opportunities and we need
to disrupt aging to help people
confront their challenges
and embrace their opportunities
to the fullest extent possible.
That requires changing the way we
talk about aging from something
to fear, to something
to look forward to
and this change is long overdue.
To start, there 3 areas for change
is most needed for individuals
in our society and I refer to
them as health, wealth and self.
I believe we can create a society
where all people can grow older
knowing that they have access
to the care information
services they need to live longer
and healthier and more
independent lives.
Where we have the financial
resources and opportunities
to match our longer life expectancy
and where we're seen is an
integral part of a society
and an aspirational asset.
By focusing on health ,wealth and
self, disrupt aging is beginning
to alter the mindsets around aging.
Fortunately, age disrupters are
everywhere like you in this room
and we don't have to
look far to find them.
As the boomers move into their 50s
and 60s and now beginning this year
into their 70s, their
disrupting aging everyday just
as they have done with other
aspects of their lives.
Millennials are also
disrupting aging
by the way they're demanding a
work-like balance their jobs.
How they're showing us the benefits
of this economic model
and shared communities.
You know my Angeloo [phonetic]
once said that at 50 each
of us finally becomes the person
we've always wanted to be.
I think that's true.
I believe that age and experience
can expand the possibilities in life
for every member of society and
when we disrupt aging and embrace it
as a part of life to
move forward to,
we can begin to discover the real
possibilities of living a live
that we've always thought.
In closing, I'd like to
leave you with this thought.
On January 6th, 1941, President
Franklin Delano Roosevelt stood
before a joint session of congress
to deliver his annual State
of the Union address in that
speech Roosevelt argued for an end
to the isolationist policies
they grew out of World War I
and offered a new ideology
based on four freedoms;
the Freedom of Speech,
Freedom of Worship,
Freedom from Want,
and Freedom from Fear.
Roosevelt's four freedoms
became a rallying cry
to guard a public support
for America's involvement
in World War II.
They resonated with the
American people as a statement
of the country's underlying
values and to this day,
Roosevelt's four freedoms reigns
through as the basic values
that defines American life and
examples of American acceptualism.
Indeed this forum, this book
festival here today is a living
testament to the core
democratic values of free speech.
In much the same way as Roosevelt's
four freedoms inspired America
to wake up and realize what was
happening in the world and to act.
I have identified what I call
the four freedoms of aging
that will define our new vision
from living and aging America
and to inspire us to continue
to disrupt aging making
that vision a reality.
The first one, the
freedom to choose how
and where you want
to live as you age.
When it comes to aging,
there is no one size fits.
If you want to follow
traditional path
to retirement you should
be able to do that.
If want to stay active engaged, you
should have the options is to pursue
that as well and whether you want
to continue living in your own home
as you get older or move to
retirement community or live
in an institutional setting,
those options should be
yours to choose from.
It's all about having
options that allow you
to choose how you want
to live and age.
The second freedom, the
freedom to earn a key part
of the retirement model
that most of us grew
up with was the freedom from work.
Today a key the part
of that extended middle
age is the freedom to work.
Many of us want or need to continue
earning a living and are searching
for ways to make a difference in a
society through the work that we do
and this requires reimagining
work and breaking
down both social institutional
barriers that stand in the way.
The third freedom,
the freedom to learn.
Our world is changing so
fast, new technologies,
new ways of communicating
with each other,
new ways of receiving end
processing information it's hard
for some of us to keep up.
If we want to stay
engaged, involved,
and productive during this
extended middle age and beyond,
we need to keep learning.
If we want to continue working
we need to keep learning in order
to keep our job skills up-to-date.
We need to keep learning in order
to avoid isolation and we need
to keep learning for our
own personal fulfillment
and to simply enjoying life.
But let's face it, the opportunities
for us to keep learning seem
to diminish as we get older and in
many cases they're just not there.
As we continue to disrupt aging we
hope to bring down those barriers
and to create new opportunities
to learn as we get older.
And the fourth freedom, the freedom
to pursue happiness by discovering
and fulfilling your purpose in life.
We have the power to reimagine
our lives to change course
and discover new ways
of fulfillment.
Civil Rights leader, A. Philip
Randolph keenly observed
that freedom is never given.
It is one.
Winning these four freedoms
begins with each of us.
We can't afford to sit on the
sidelines and wait for someone else
to win these freedoms for us.
We have to do this ourselves.
It's time to tell our stories about
what we believe and what we can do.
So I ask you in your conversations
with your family and your friends,
what beliefs will you start
to challenge in your own life?
In your life and in your work,
what solutions will you spark?
In everything you do, think
about what new possibilities you can
create for yourself and for others
and what are you going to do
to continue disrupt aging?
Disrupt aging is our rallying cry
to create a new vision for living
and aging in the 21st century.
Our new vision is about a world
which aging is not a
decline, it's about growth.
It doesn't present only challenges
it also creates opportunities
and older people are not burdens
to society, they're contributors.
When we disrupt aging and embrace
it as something to look forward
to instead of something to fear,
we began to discover
the real possibilities
for becoming the person we've always
wanted be and to build a society
where each of us are
valued for who we are
as a person not how old we are.
I hope you enjoy the "Disrupt
Aging" book and I would love
to the answer any of your questions.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Questions?
Yes.
>> I'm wondering what some
legal help [inaudible] and.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: They're going
to give you a mic right there.
[ Inaudible ]
>> It's a meeting halfway.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks.
I'm a journalist.
I tell my young journalism
friends that the 60s
so far has been my best decade as
far as journalism goes and halfway
through the next decade now it's,
this one's looking good too.
But I'm wondering about
some legal help
for certain areas of discrimination.
For instance, I have applied a
couple years now for some grants
that I really think I can
contribute to and the first question
on the grant application is
the date of birth and your age
and I just find that why would
you need to know that for a grant.
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: So the question
was about age discrimination
and what avenues of
redress to have that?
I would say to you that, and
it's probably not any shock
that age discrimination
is alive and well,
we certainly see it particularly
in the workplace and so I know
that I will just speak for AARP in
saying that, we have a whole staff
of legal team who works on
age discrimination every day.
And really trying to address and see
the systemic barriers that created
around age discrimination,
so I would have suggest
that you either contact
your local AARP office
and I'm sure they would be
more than are willing to help.
I will also add that
for the first time
in history we're seeing
5 generations
in the workplace at one time.
If you're assuming that
interns are coming in at18
and people are working until
their you know 90s or 100s
and the whole spectrum of
what the workforce will look
like in the future is dramatically
changing and we also have to adjust
to that workplace and figure
out how do we bring the value
of all those generations together
and so it's going to be; you know,
I often talk about for most of
us we went to work at 1 place
or maybe 2 places and if we were
looking at somebody's resume
and had jumped around
to 5 or 6 year jobs,
we probably didn't call them
back in for a second interview.
Today, the norm is that if you are
staying somewhere over 3 or 4 years,
you're probably be
stagnant in the workplace
and that people are having 10
to 15 different places of work.
The workplace of the
future is going to be
that not only people are working
10 to 15 different places,
but they're going to have
3 or 4 totally careers
and so this whole idea of the
freedom to learn is how we need
to start engaging so that
having that college degree
or that master's degree isn't going
to be good enough for you to be able
to compete in the workplace
that is changing dramatically
with respected technology and some
of the way the world is changing.
So important for us
to continue to learn
and keep pace with
those technologies.
Other questions?
I can't really see anything.
Yes. Yes please.
>> My name is Naomi
and I am 59-and-a-half
and I did celebrate that.
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: Great.
>> My question is, thank you.
My question is, okay so you're
saying all these people are aging
into the 100s and da-da-da-da,
and soon we'll be 150,
so what are going to
do retire at 130?
I mean that sound like
all the much fun to me.
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: I would say
to you that I've been throwing
out this idea that somehow we
need to move middle age from 50
to past 65, because we're
going to have an extra 30 years
to do something very meaningful
in our life or to continue to work
at a time period of when
social security and Medicare
and those programs
were put in place.
People were expecting to retire at
65 and life expectancy was 67 or 68.
And you heard me say earlier
that the fastest growing age
group is people of the age of 85.
But we can't just tack
on to the end of our life
and decide oh I have 10 extra
years what am I going to do?
We're going to have to rethink
for those particularly those
on the younger end, rethink how
you're going to plan financially.
We don't want to outlive our income
and we certainly want to be able
to live comfortably in doing that.
And so how do we start thinking
about our social support system
in this country, because
we're actually better off
than most countries around the world
in terms of our support systems
around social security and Medicare
and those kinds of programs.
But each of us are
going to have to think
through our own personal
health; how we're living,
whether we're exercising
and eating healthier,
and think about how we need a plan
accordingly so that we don't get
that end of life and be in poor
health for some 10 or 15 years.
That would be the worst
thing that could happen.
We need to make sure there we're
many healthier and taking care
of ourselves and exercising
and doing all those things,
so that that period of declined,
because we all will have that period
of decline, will be condensed
hopefully in that, you know 3 to,
2 to 3 year period rather than
10 to 15 year caregiving phase.
I think we have time
for one more question.
>> Good afternoon.
Florence Navarro.
I'm the executive director
of a nonprofit called
Empowered Women International.
We train women in this region
to start their own business
and so my question to you is we
actually see quite a few women
who come to us to prepare for their
retirement and they want to build
on their passion, on their
skills to start a business
to complement their retirement.
What do, what is your
view on entrepreneurship
and [inaudible] starting their
own business and what kind
of help should be provided
or could be provided?
Thank you.
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: Thank you for
question and 2 important facts;
women are the fastest growing users
of technology and social media,
as well as, starting
their own businesses.
So, this is a particular area for
everyone, but especially for women
as we think about those skills that
we've developed over the course
of these years and I know that
it's important and there's a lot
of online information as well
as through the small business
administration that talks
about the preparations, so
not just to have a great idea,
but also how do you have a
financial and business plan
around that business idea.
Because more and more of us are
going to be independent workers
or self-employed contractors
servicing the private sector
and so it's important that
we get those skillsets
and that we're willing to take
that leap of faith to take
that great idea and turn into a
business, so thank you for the work
that guys are doing and
it's a growing field and all
of us need to be engaged in that.
They're telling me 1 more question.
Yes.
>> This is a question of all the
time you've spoken I've not heard
the word senior and hopefully
that senior only refers
to something associated
with discount.
But my real question you mentioned
about choices of places to be
and maybe you would talk a little
bit about aging and community?
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: And I would
say I rarely use the word senior
because I think we ought to be
judging people about their abilities
and that term senior seems to imply,
in my mind, that this is you're
in your last phase of
life ready to graduate.
And so I know I personally
don't use that,
because it to me you can't
judge somebody by an age,
but about their abilities.
So important that we
think about how we build
out what we call livable
communities.
How do we get mayors
and county officials
to start building communities
that from day one allow people
to age in their own community?
Important factual information
that we've been seeing
over last couple years is that,
there is a closer relationship
between millennials and boomers
than any other age
segments in the country.
They like to live in community.
They want to work 5 to 10
minutes from their own home.
They want the flexibility to
be in work and out of work.
I see a little millennial sitting
here and she's shaking her head
to sort of do that, and
transportation is important.
You've seen these whole
charity colony models of people
like companies of like
Lift and Uber.
They, when they setup
these companies it was
to solve a millennial problem
of how do we around in a place
that we don't actually want to have
the burden of paying a car note and
yet we want the flexibility
to do that?
When ARB and B started, they had
no idea; I was talking to a woman
who had started was one of the
cofounders of ARB and B and she said
to us, "We never anticipated that
the users of ARB and B were going
to be over the age of 50."
Same thing with Lift and Uber
that they tell us that some
of their best drivers
are over the age of 50.
They show up for work on time.
They don't get in accidents
contrary to what people say
about older workers,
and that it's important
that they have the
flexibility to bring that,
all that additional
income in society.
I hope you; time is up.
I thank you for coming.
We're going to be signing books
in just a few minutes down at the
"Disrupt Aging" booth,
so thank you very much
and I appreciate your time today.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.